ah
no no estoy diciendo que no te veas
linda estás preciosa lo que digo es que
yo no me lo pondría está bien tienes
todo el derecho a ser aburrida
[Música]
todas lucimos lindas zona somos lindas
yo vine por sus atuendos son entonces
por donde quieren comenzar cómo se
sienten
me mires bueno comienzo yo mi
inspiración es la estética del año 2000
me encanta barbie y espero no haberme
puesto estos zapatos incómodos para nada
me duelen los pies espero ser la mejor
vez es gracioso que hayas mencionado la
barby forte tan pronto te me pensé
parece
y me dijeron pero creo que el atuendo de
ella también es genial sí me gusta mucho
tu atuendo me parece coherente y nunca
había visto algo así esta cartera con
forma de ataúd me parece muy linda la
compra en una tienda de disfraces me
gusta mucho mi atuendo me siento bien
pero no soy soy muy tímida para decir no
me importa lo que digan soy la mejor
vestida ron dirigencial del cni así que
me ubicaría en la mitad sé que mi estilo
es un poco intimidante porque es un poco
oscuro y opuesto a mi personalidad me
gusta tu estilo es un poco steampunk y
un poco victoriano por el corsé estás
muy comprometida con tu look y tu
atuendo yo creo que sí soy la mejor
vestida o al menos la segunda me siento
muy cómoda con mi estilo para mí es una
especie de estilo antiguo hollywoodense
y vintage eso es lo que realmente me
gusta quería mostrar mi estilo y quería
ver si alguien más podía identificarse
con mi atuendo el look clásico no ha
muerto y si sientes que puedes llevarlo
entonces hazlo como ya estoy en la
posición de mejor vestida así
simplemente me quedaré aquí es una broma
hablando cuando tenía dudas sobre qué
pantalón ponerme así que no me puse
definitivamente pensaba que tenía que ir
más allá tenía que pensar en el mejor
atuendo del mundo pero tuve que buscar
otra perspectiva y pensar que me pondría
en el día a día para que la gente se
haga una idea de mi estilo el bolso lo
compré porque es de una marca negra
quiero apoyar a los artistas negros a
los empresarios negros y todo lo demás
está tan bien logrado los colores con
bienes ángeles
yo seré la número uno luego tú tú eres
la tercera número cuatro la del ataúd y
número cinco
la chica barbie esté bien tienes todo el
de dónde nacer a bendecir dónde te ves
bien solo que es muy difícil comparar
pero broma es broma no estoy diciendo
que no te veas linda estás preciosa lo
que digo es que yo no me lo pondría y
día por la calle rogando que nadie me
viera no sé es lindo pero no mete siendo
bueno no me lo van a creer pero siento
que mi atuendo de hoy es tan aburrido
lo pensé y decidí moderarme un poco
porque sabía que no debería venir en un
vestido de fiesta nuestros gustos son
parecidos vamos en el mismo universo
bardi gótica y tú la normal yo pondría a
hayley de primera luego isa yo me
pondría de tercera anna de cuarta y lex
de última yo me pondría de primera
aunque suene arrogante luego pondría a
esa
celeste de tercera
lex de cuarta y hayley de quinta de
acuerdo yo me pondría de primera sin
duda creo que mi atuendo es la cúspide
del estilo y no espero todo el mundo
definitivamente pero para mí sí lo es
soy la reina del estrafalario y pondría
a celeste de segunda aisha de tercera
álex de cuarta y ana de quinta bueno
para mí yo soy la mejor vestida luego le
ex porque es otro atuendo que
seguramente me pondría en brasilia así
celeste la tercera hayley de cuarta la
última pondría a na porque aunque no sea
mi estilo creo que ella se ve genial
y que estoy detención en método de
youtube de cuarta quinta y segunda
primera y cebolla
severa y de primera creo que a todos
creo que su estilo no me gustó a todos
los artesanales
yo movería celeste sí creo que debería
ir antes bien estoy bien aquí de segunda
yo creo que ver dos bien de segunda así
me ve todo el mundo me ama no me odian
entonces soy 50 y 50 voy a ser yo no
quiero estar de tercera pero tiene
sentido
ya estoy bien aquí igual yo ni me parece
bien me conformaré no me satisface
demasiado ser la última pero al mismo
tiempo refleja como la sociedad actual
de la moda así que valoro ver esa
perspectiva especialmente de gente de mi
edad
podrían ponerse los audífonos
[Música]
bueno nos toca decidir esto y comencemos
no no no no
no
muy bien esperen vayamos en orden y
comentemos lo que pensamos sobre cada
uno por uno obviamente me gusta mirar
los detalles me gusta prestarles
atención en cada edición me gusta el
estampado de cebra me gustan todos los
elementos del atuendo la dejaría de
primera podrías mostrarme tu bolso
si eso es eso me llega de verdad es una
marca negra ella se ve genial me gusta
está lista para todo tiene una intención
en su estilo me gusta yo pondría a la
cebra de segunda debió usar zapatos más
altos como zapatos de plataforma digo no
arrastraría los pantalones como bien
quiero que los pantalones resalten más a
mí me gusta la segunda sinceramente me
gusta su atuendo andrógino yo me lo
pondría todo ese atuendo se ve como muy
pulcro si piensas cómo lucen todos los
detalles que tiene ese atuendo y son
bastante coherentes en lo personal no me
gustan los pantalones
los demás se ven bien me gusta el
atuendo de barbie solo porque es el
único que resalta sin dudas resalta y le
llevaría mi no me gusta el vestido si
llama la atención yo también llamo las
aves solo que no me gustan o no me gusta
el estampado parece una realmente yo la
pondría de cuarta la barbie parecía
fuera de lugar en mi opinión se veía
como si pensara oye esto es demasiado
para mí la cuarta no sé por qué pero me
gusta mucho incluso si no es lo que
suele gustarme es atractivo además la
cartera está los anillos y todo lo demás
es genial su atuendo con botas se ve
mejor que el de barbie quisiera que
usará los dos guantes y un solo guante
es un buen toque
bien si tuviera los dos guantes dirías
que sé por la quinta vi su atuendo y
creía que crees que está en el grupo
creo que no se sentía cómoda me recuerda
a las maestras del colegio sí sí creo
que se parece a mary poppins
y la verdad no lo tolero creo que puedo
hacer algo más ya saben como una
gabardina
ella dijo que se identifica con el
estilo vintage y su atuendo tiene ese
estilo sin duda entiendo lo que quiere
qué loco me parece que trabajan juntos
pensé que la pondría en tercer lugar o
algo así
primero siquiera sabes qué tipo de
persona es cierto para mí deben estar de
primera y 61 es mejor ir de oro y plata
creo que es algo blanco podría ser euros
y la primera entre todas ellas sí yo
diría que de cuarto a los otros chicos
les encantó el chaleco blanco pero yo
sentía que le faltaba algo a ese atuendo
el conjunto de cebra de segunda también
la pondría decía cebra la cebra va a
decir de tercera
las movemos también sé
muy bien muy bien vamos con la barbie
qué piensan creo que el vestido negro es
mucho mejor
ella me recuerda harley quinn eso era lo
que estaba tratando de recordar todo
este rato sí y creo que ellas deben
intercambiarse sí que se rueden ustedes
intercambien se les parece bien chicos
está bien creo que hasta parece bien
estoy de acuerdo si creo que es el único
que está bien sí
[Música]
pensé que los chicos iban a decir si es
muy sexy ponla de primera y van a decir
es demasiado es muy exagerada ponla de
última no me sorprende pase por fases en
las que tenía el cabello corto y me
vestía como un chico skater y ahora me
he visto así entonces llegué a mi estilo
adulto me critican por ser así antes
decían eres demasiado masculina y ahora
eres demasiado femenina me hubiera
gustado no quedar de última pero estoy
orgullosa de ese lugar porque si quedé
en último lugar entre las chicas y los
chicos significa que no soy del agrado
de todos pero hay una cierta cantidad de
gente con la que realmente me puedo
relacionar y puedo formar un grupo de
compañeros sólido en lugar de querer
agradarle a todos está bien no somos
translúcidos para mí no deberías
preocuparte porque al final del día
mientras estés contenta con lo que
llevas puesto tienes razón misma
adelante sigue con tubey me gusta que
cada una tiene un estilo diferente y
todos nos vemos maravillosas en realidad
todas tenemos el mejor atuendo del mundo
yo uso lo que quiera y alguien usted
tendrá que soportar la
jubilee vive intensamente